plus de lignes plus de rotations plus de
secteurs desservis et de meilleures
correspondances avec les trains depuis
ce lundi modifications sur le réseau de
bus ski bus autour de la zone
d'activités de trappes elancourt le
parcours de la ligne 402 a été modifié
avec un terminus en gare de trappes la
ligne 4 115 qui dessert la croix
bonnaire bois d'arcy a été renforcée
c'est par exemple un bus toutes les 7 et
8 minutes entre la gare de saint-quentin
et bois d'arcy église deux nouvelles
lignes la 430 et la 431 ont été créés
depuis la gare de trappes et depuis les
villes de trappes elancourt pour mieux
desservir donc la zone d'activités qui
compte près de 7000 salariés le coût
total du projet est de 280 11000 euros
financé par le stif les communautés
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines versailles grand parc mais
aussi par les entreprises de la croix
bonnaire d'arcy et l'association de la
zone d'activités
l'encours